[Music]
and can't touch this
no not so enthusiastic submitted by Sony
the Hedgehog yu-gi-oh yeah yeah yeah but
that was like 2016 bro
a woman ate her entire life savings to
prevent her husband from having it
what a [ __ ] what's up with these
people in this world what
trick-or-treating located she ate the
[ __ ] classic
the paper countersue / - oh really
cash money there was unless you want to
check and then she ate a check or
something or pretty the cash Marion in a
location that he can't find stupid that
was make sense so she's dead now
all dude this is a Chinese woman slum
bein one of course
Oh what what not do you know Xena's
Burnet they don't eat it not be
miserable
wait they don't eat it all right smells
I don't say that [ __ ] Latinas are mucho
okay no we're not all right we're good
and Martina ladies so mucho loco as you
passionate we just got fire we got the
[ __ ] professionalism a lot of things
for no reason is the problem actually
the [ __ ] got me a [ __ ] number two
thankfully she talked like you deal with
a lot being well she wasn't Mexican no
it's better she let you know yeah okay
the same thing with you better as yours
looks better than all your babies at a
Mexican what the [ __ ] are you talking
about I don't know what the with the mob
a madness Peppino that's right when it
comes I was gonna be a little Filipino
baby true yeah so this woman her name is
Sandra Sandra 228 years old she had been
saving about nine thousand dollars US
dollars a million dollars there too or
no a British and I didn't use a cocaine
okay no because some places they use the
US dollars for the local currencies like
Cambodia oh you can't bring [ __ ]
whorehouse
it's into the discussion of course the
dollars accepted everywhere and every
whorehouse and every time ago I have
never been you can't go to before but
this is what you will told me nervous no
horse no I never how I think about it
you say not come back writer I can try
I've never been a book on a podium sorta
funny Cambodia no more houses
I had never been a catalyst as anyway
better you that was are offended about
wrote that's [ __ ] hilarious
I do not have that straight amazed I had
the other one cuz anyways so Sandra
found out that her husband was being a
lazy little cheater and so what's wrong
with that what you want me to teach you
don't get the fire ignited he's bidding
Excel I've seen them and I'm not wait
between two men I know but but I think
you know that I spray she's quite mellow
then why were you complaining about how
latina is so stupid because I grew up in
a very multi-ethnic area Sacramento
California and I'm observant of it
they're very firing and they're very
beautiful hmm you got a double-edged
sword you know I mean things could be
Wow okay give us the gin thank you it's
a compliment nobody call oh yeah they're
so curvaceous you're beautiful you
develop early got the best food on earth
let's leave it out nod you guys are
[ __ ] I'm true and we have Korean
girls are way more of the [ __ ] yeah
but they're yeah they're great
well the only girl that I dated that was
Korean that stuck around it was Mariel
cuz she's crazy today with you haha I
love you Mary oh you crazy no but I uh
dated two other Korean girls didn't like
it did not like it at all very combative
very hey you haven't know the cradled me
oh yeah I hated it
the Muriel's great though super-sweet
not clinging she's very career-driven
she has her own friends her own life and
then every now and then I'm allowed to
enter it no sir she's permission yeah
you know what's not funny way so Santa's
has been found this hidden stash of
money that Sandra had and he started
demanding half of it he was like half of
a shoe is mine
so it's her money to begin with he found
it who wants half her so she ate so half
No so then she just like they had this
huge argument they were yelling and
hitting each other according to the
housemates that lives with him and and
so apparently the housemate says a he
was shouting that half the millet is she
was in a fit of rage and that's what she
swallowed my mommy
kollene even possible yeah yeah ah now
Julia ribbon in group six is a rolling
it oh my god how much time did he sit
there watching that yeah you're going to
go ahead in the middle of five and as
she's broke and probably has a bunch of
diseases okay so the next day she went
to the hospital so she had severe
abdominal course that's when the police
or the hospital thought that she had
been swallowing drugs for like illegal
transport but then they discovered that
it was in fact as muddy to rage yeah and
so they report that they found 57 $100
bills left they they extract it out of a
hole that that cuts her stomach whoosh
hey welcome back to original unit so not
all the money was able to be salvaged
only about 5,700 of it was
especially laughs damn 4000 plus the
hospital bills oh yeah you failed
doesn't that's a problem with Latinas
they already think things through
the shoulders or that you're a bigot
remove the phone you just get all fired
up and they just started acting on [ __ ]
and then later on they're like that way
so [ __ ] though you know what still
happy your child is that they're looking
at 100% but you're a Spaniard [ __ ]
though you sound crazy
she also grew up in East LA special
round one that's right from my eyes yeah
I completely understand now you don't
know what you're talking butter brown
wash and then all of Mexico you've only
seen us - though I'm just referring it
to you we got to make a Mexico trip and
you're going to your job in the Mexico
three times and for a [ __ ] church
retreat you own in a hideous place I
have been with the heart of the city so
that's basically what comes yet no you
have not I have bent it up you went to
the tortilla statue in the heart of the
city it's a giant floating tortilla
we're going to take you to Mexico and
your jaws gonna [ __ ] drop you're
gonna be like all the bomb drop when I
saw what was going on into Juwanna yeah
that's like the worst part to go to I
don't really but I'm like yo it's so
heartbreaking gold yeah we're not going
it's not we're arguing the wrong I don't
want to go to the Beverly Hills I'm not
trying to take you to the Sun Hat out
where we're from there you are not Mason
yeah a beautiful oh you're gonna do this
something is you starting off with it
yeah
yeah but here's a photo a very bad
quality holy [ __ ] the money extracted
imagine our smells right there I just
don't think it's Mel smellin a dollar
bill dollars grant gastric juices yeah
the other thing about the rest of the
money I've destroyed because of the
gastric juice happy we should
investigate where this person got this
Nokia phone because this is some grainy
[ __ ] I think they put vaseline on it
okay there you go
take it a little left I think it's a
still from a video that's why well take
me to Mexico so I could see your people
in this flourishing Spaniard glory how
long is the flight to Guadalajara three
and a half hours there's no claim there
then I go to a different city and the I
rent document what is it you're nothing
you're not too far off at least from
where my mom grew up like her town you
catch the flight which is three hours
and then there's a one-hour bus drive to
that town god there's no direct where
does she live in a cave Oakland Oakland
out lon it's an aspect design in helical
Alanya I want to go see the Mayan ruins
of [ __ ] though the Aztec [ __ ] thank you
can come saloon thank you it wasn't as
impressive as the photo booklet really
Casey and I went like years ago and I
was like this but it's amazing when I
see that stuff because people back in
the day without the modern technology
built something like that and we're
gonna eat a murdered mother flashing
they used to take people's heart out and
sacrifice it to the [ __ ] God that is
morbid as hell and I imagine that [ __ ]
and it's pretty [ __ ] here really so
domestic or net I'm down it's cheap to
frigging I want to see you girls get in
fights with other Latinas I'll back you
up
we're moms now we don't do that I'm home
mom oh look oh look oh no I mean if you
want that's not saying Mexico we're just
gonna literally only be there for the
beach because it's all tourists I'm
going was only Guanajuato or one of us
because I'm in iguana Hoffler dude
really in town yeah we are in many ways
like no there's no what you're going to
say over there the matter
stance I didn't see any banana stands
there but that was that was like a very
like touristy place right but then I
thought it does a lot of locals there as
well
yeah I guess that's a different state hi
guys hope that was an insightful episode
of Jessica dnews please stay close to
every single person in this video by
cruising on over to the description box
and following us on Instagram for more
videos click right over here
[Music]